[Music]
to spoil their success
just because the plateaus is so good
that even if you smile i somewhat agree
yeah
so i think yeah but we haven't we
haven't discussed the plot i mean that's
true so i think it depends on the plot
if it's uh
but both both are great movies so you
should watch them yeah if you haven't
and we won't
meanwhile my opponent is playing a
little bit too soft here
and as far as i can remember from last
time we do have auto queen now on now
yeah we turn it on so you can
do whatever you want
rook f1 i win f2
he does give it a little bit of counter
play but i don't think it's going to be
enough
if you need to promote to a knight you
can hold down control
control okay yeah or a bishop or rick
anything you can promote anything man uh
you can promote to anything you want to
yeah
okay i don't know why he's fighting he's
probably hoping for some kind of paid
uh yeah we'll take this one i'm not
gonna take your b pawn
i could have taken these people i was
just
no
not going to get any chances for paid
okay um